bonjour à tous j'espère que vous avez passé
un bel été bienvenue dans mon bureau dans
le bureau de passer sauvage c'est pas tous
les jours que vous pouvez le regarder si on
commence ici c'est parce que je vais vous
présenter ce qui s'affiche à mon écran
il s'agit de nextory qui sponsorise une nouvelle
fois une vidéo sur passé sauvage et Merci
beaucoup à eux de me faire confiance nextory
c'est une application de lecture mais qui
a la particularité de proposer tous les formats
podcast BD presse livre audio ebook j'ai de
nouveau épluché leur catalogue et j'ai trouvé
des choses incroyables vraiment des surprises
notamment une collection qui s'appelle les
grandes voix co-édité avec le CNRS ça a
l'air génial je sais pas pourquoi je connaissais
pas ça avant il y en a un sur le climat ce
qui me suivent sur Instagram savent que c'est
un thème qui m'intéresse énormément cette
année suivez-moi sur Instagram d'ailleurs
si vous voulez être tenu au courant de ce
qui va sortir il y en a un autre sur la révolution
néolithique bah oui ça très bien on prend
il y a du evaillous pourquoi l'amour fait
mal on veut savoir ça a l'air très très
bien let's Godelier là suivre Jésus et faire
du business rien que pour le titre le sens
de la formule on y va et sinon toujours dans
cette fameuse collection CNRS qu'on nous avait
caché visiblement qu'est-ce qu'on trouve
du Christian Ingrao et du Yoann chaputo moi
je suis pourquoi mon teint fan club ingra
au chaputo ce qui sont d'accord bah mentionnez-vous
en commentaire voilà pour les découvertes
je vous mets toutes ces références dans
la barre d'information avec le lien évidemment
qui vous permet de tester cette application
vous avez trois abonnements disponibles tous
les détails sont très bien expliqués sur
l'application grâce à ce lien qui s'affiche
ici vous avez accès à une période d'essai
de 45 jours offert au lieu de 14 habituellement
sur l'abonnement standard encore une fois
tout est très bien expliqué sur nextory
donc je vous souhaite une bonne découverte
une bonne lecture et on enchaîne avec la
vidéo du jour Il y a des sujets comme ça…
qui sont assez délicats.
On a d’ailleurs jamais rechigné à les
traiter sur cette chaîne.
On a déjà parlé ici de la théorie afrocentriste
ou du débat sur les origines des juifs d’Europe
de l’Est qui fait rage entre les historiens
israéliens.
A chaque fois, ça a provoqué de très nombreux
commentaires, parfois très énervés et pas
toujours polis.
Mais il y a eu aussi beaucoup de réactions
positives et constructives et ça me donne
envie de continuer à traiter de sujets “sensibles”,
sans les laisser aux idéologues et autres
polémistes.
Le voile, ce morceau de tissu qui est rabattu
sur la tête, fait partie de ces sujets sensibles.
Parce qu’il touche à la religion, à l’identité
et qu’il met face à face des visions du
monde opposées, ce n’est pas un sujet neutre,
et on ne peut pas faire comme si ça n’allait
froisser personne.
Froisser…, tissu…, vous l’avez ? Et
il se trouve que les historiens, les anthropologues
et les sociologues ont pas mal de choses à
dire là-dessus.
En s’attachant à comparer, à replacer
dans le contexte et à démêler les enjeux,
ils nous font relativiser pas mal de choses.
Ce serait quand même dommage d’abandonner
ce sujet à la presse de droite parce que
le sujet n’est pas toujours traité avec
recul et nuance, on va pas se voiler la face…
Bon OK, on va arrêter les calembours douteux,
et vous l’avez compris, on va essayer aujourd’hui
de faire une rapide histoire du voile, et
de ses différents usages.
Bien sûr, toutes les sources sont en description
pour appuyer et prolonger ce qui est dit dans
la vidéo.
C’est quoi un voile ?
Il faut commencer par l’essentiel.
C’est quoi un voile ? En fait c’est à
la fois simple et compliqué.
Le voile dans sa définition la plus générale,
c’est un vêtement non-cousu qui couvre
la tête.
C’est un pan de tissu, rien de plus.
Mais il peut être porté d’une infinité
de manière : couvrir toute la tête, seulement
une partie ou descendre sur le visage, il
peut être transparent, épais, ajouré, il
peut y avoir des plis, des ornements, ou même
plusieurs couches…
Dans l’histoire, le voile a servi pour de
nombreux usages.
Que ce soit pour les femmes ou pour les hommes.
En fait, le voile est un moyen simple et commode
d’instaurer une distance entre soi et les
autres.
Par exemple, le port du chèche chez les Touaregs
ne peut pas être expliqué que par un aspect
purement pratique, pour se protéger du sable
et du soleil.
C’est d’abord pour cacher son visage à
ses proches, c’est le signe d’une honorabilité.
Face à un étranger, le dévoilement est
plus aisé car il y a moins d’enjeu à afficher
un statut social.
Pour l’historienne Nicole Pellegrin, “le
voile crée donc un espace d’autonomie et
d’estime de soi autour du corps qu’il
revêt”.
En Europe, pendant longtemps, rabattre un
pan de tissu sur la tête était un signe
de deuil pour les hommes et les femmes, cela
permettait de cacher ses émotions et de porter
sur soi la gravité du moment.
Aujourd’hui, sari, fichu, foulard, chèche,
turban, bandana et autre keffieh sont des
vêtements du quotidien pour une grande partie
de l’humanité.
Mais vous le savez, ce ne sont pas ces usages
qui font du voile un sujet sensible.
C’est davantage son utilisation comme symbole
religieux et en particulier pour les femmes.
C’est toujours sur nous que ça tombe…
Pour comprendre d’où vient cet usage religieux
et aussi pourquoi il s’est imposé de manière
aussi stricte sur le corps des femmes, il
faut remonter à l’Antiquité.
Le voile dans l’Antiquité
L’une des premières mentions d’un voile
imposé aux femmes provient d’une tablette
cunéiforme assyrienne, datée aux alentours
de 1100 avant J.-C.
Découverte à Assur, dans le nord de l’Irak
actuel, la tablette en question conserve plus
de 750 lignes de texte et détaille en 59
articles le droit matrimonial et le statut
des femmes.
On y apprend que les femmes mariées devaient
à cette époque avoir la tête couverte dans
l’espace public.
C’est une mention rapide dont on connaît
mal les contours précis, mais elle permet
d’inscrire le port du voile féminin dans
une longue tradition.
Plus proche de nous, en Grèce antique, le
voile pouvait marquer un statut social ou
un moment particulier de la vie, mais il n’avait
sans doute rien d’obligatoire ni de signification
très rigide.
On le voit avec les tanagras, ces petites
statuettes qui représentent le plus souvent
des femmes.
Certaines ont la tête couverte, et d’autres
non.
C’est plutôt lors de moments importants
que les têtes se couvrent de tissu, pour
marquer la peine pendant un deuil par exemple.
L’autre moment décisif où les femmes se
voilent la tête en Grèce, c’est lors de
leur mariage.
Certains vases qui représentent des mariages
le montrent très bien, même s’il existe
aussi des mariages où les femmes ont la tête
nue.
A l'issue de la cérémonie, elles peuvent
offrir ce voile à une divinité, notamment
Héra, protectrice des femmes et déesse du
mariage.
Le dévoilement devient ainsi une métaphore
du consentement.
La femme qui se dévoile pour son époux accepte
symboliquement son sort.
C’est un prélude à l’acte sexuel.
Car le voile en Grèce possède aussi une
dimension érotique.
Il souligne le caractère désirable de la
femme qui le porte.
Les étoffes les plus nobles et des couleurs
chatoyantes servent à souligner le visage
et les courbes des jeunes femmes.
Porté plus sobrement, il devient le symbole
du lien entre une femme et son époux et il
n’est plus arboré par les veuves, qui montrent
ainsi la fin de leur statut marital.
Un peu plus tard, dans la Rome antique, le
voile sert aussi au moment du mariage, mais
c’est avant tout un signe religieux.
Le fait de se couvrir la tête concerne à
Rome tout le monde, homme ou femme, dès lors
qu’il s’agit de participer à un rite
religieux, contrairement au monde grec où
l’on sacrifie tête découverte.
Les prêtres romains sont ainsi désignés
par l’expression capite velato, “la tête
voilée”.
Les statues d’empereurs tête voilée soulignent
ainsi leur rôle de grand pontife, chef de
la religion, en train de réaliser un rite.
On le voit par exemple sur certaines statues
d’Auguste ou sur la Colonne trajane où
l’empereur réalise le sacrifice avant son
expédition militaire.
L’historien antique Plutarque explique cette
habitude par le besoin de s’empêcher de
voir ou d’entendre des signes de mauvais
augure au moment d’accomplir le rite.
En se couvrant les yeux et les oreilles, le
sacrifiant se consacre entièrement à son
rituel.
Chez les femmes romaines, ce sont d’abord
les Vestales qui portent le voile.
Prêtresses consacrées à Vesta, la déesse
du foyer, vivant recluses et chastes, elles
portent un voile qui recouvre leur tête.
On peut vraiment les considérer comme les
ancêtres des nonnes chrétiennes.
Dans la vie courante, les femmes romaines
portent souvent une palla, un voile qui s’avance
sur le haut du crâne mais laisse découverte
la chevelure et les oreilles, mais cela n’a
sans doute rien d’obligatoire dans l’espace
public.
En revanche, la coiffure représente un enjeu
bien plus important.
Les vittae, bandelettes qui ornent les tresses
affirment le statut de femme mariée, de matrone,
et doivent être portées dans la rue.
D’autres coiffures élégantes marquant
ce statut marital peuvent être arborées,
telles que la mitra, un large bandeau, mais
ça n’a rien à voir avec la foi religieuse
avant le christianisme.
Le voile : une invention chrétienne
Car tout change avec le christianisme.
Cette nouvelle religion qui se diffuse dans
l’Empire romain, cherche à prendre ses
distances avec le judaïsme, dont elle est
issue.
Car dans la Bible Hébraïque, le texte sacré
des juifs, le voile n’est jamais mentionné
comme un vêtement religieux, on l’évoque
seulement au moment du mariage de Rebecca
et Isaac, dans une tradition qui ressemble
au mariage grec ou romain.
Rien de spécial donc.
Mais les chrétiens en font un vêtement bien
plus important.
Dans la Première Épître aux Corinthiens,
qui fait partie du Nouveau Testament chrétien,
l’apôtre Paul, le véritable organisateur
de la doctrine chrétienne, recommande le
port d’un voile aux femmes mariées.
Il écrit : “Toute femme qui prie ou qui
prophétise la tête non voilée, déshonore
sa tête: elle est comme celle qui est rasée.
Si une femme ne se voile pas la tête, qu'elle
se coupe aussi les cheveux.
Or, s'il est honteux à une femme d'avoir
les cheveux coupés ou la tête rasée, qu'elle
se voile.
L'homme ne doit pas se couvrir la tête, parce
qu'il est la gloire de Dieu, tandis que la
femme est la gloire de l'homme.
[...] ce n’est pas l’homme qui a été
créé pour la femme, mais la femme pour l’homme.”
(Chapitre 11, 5-9) Bon, pour ce qui est de
l’égalité des sexes, on repassera, mais
le message a au moins le mérite d’être
clair.
La Bible chrétienne invente l’obligation
du voile pour les femmes.
Dans les premiers temps du christianisme,
d’autres théoriciens religieux insistent
sur cette nécessité.
Clément d’Alexandrie, qui écrit au début
du IIIe siècle, écrit : “il est prescrit
[aux femmes] de se couvrir la tête et de
se voiler le visage.
C’est qu’il n’est pas conforme à la
volonté divine que la beauté du corps soit
un piège à capturer les hommes.”
Dans cet esprit, ce n’est pas aux hommes
de maîtriser leurs pulsions, mais c’est
aux femmes, objets désirables, de se cacher
des hommes pour éviter d’être agressées.
Ça commence à pas me plaire.
Mais attention, il ne faudrait pas que le
voile ne devienne aussi un outil de séduction.
Après tout, on l’a vu, c’était souvent
le cas en Grèce.
Notre moraliste chrétien se dépêche donc
d’ajouter : “Et il n’est pas non plus
raisonnable qu’une femme porte un grand
voile pourpre pour attirer les regards.”
Donc un voile, mais pas trop grand, et pas
trop coloré.
Le dress-code se complique…
Cet impératif du voile féminin est encore
élargi par Tertullien, un auteur chrétien
qui écrit aussi au IIIe siècle.
Dans Le Voile des Vierges, il conseille à
toutes les femmes, vierges ou mariées de
porter un long voile tombant jusqu’à la
taille.
Il précise que c’est absolument indispensable
à l’intérieur d’une église, mais que
cela devrait aussi être le cas dans l’espace
public en général.
En employant les termes de velamen et velamentum,
on peut considérer comme l’historien Christophe
Badel que Tertullien invente véritablement
la notion de voile telle que nous la comprenons
aujourd’hui.
Dans ce texte on lit notamment : “[...] il
faut voiler nos vierges dès qu'elles sortent
de l'enfance [...]. [...] l'obligation du
voile commencera pour elle le jour où elle
peut exciter la convoitise des hommes [...]. Qui
que vous soyez, mère, sœur, fille, épouse,
n'importe l'âge et l'état, voilez votre
tête [...]. C'est le Christ qui veut que
les épouses et les fiancées des hommes soient
voilées [...]. [Le voile doit] envelopper
les épaules; car ce sont les épaules qui
doivent être soumises [...]. Le voile est
le joug des femmes.”
C’est bien hein ? On constate ici le changement
total de signification du voile.
Pour les Romains, la tête couverte était
une marque de dignité pour une mère de famille,
chez les chrétiens, elle devient une obligation
de pudeur et même un signe de soumission
à l’homme.
Le voile en islam
Dans le monde musulman, le port du voile existe
dès l’origine.
Ça vient du fait que les vêtements amples
et couvrants étaient largement répandus
chez les tribus arabes et au Moyen-Orient
en général.
On le voit par exemple sur les reliefs funéraires
de Palmyre qui datent des IIe et IIIe siècles
après J.-C. et on a parlé au début des
traditions assyriennes bien plus anciennes.
Pourtant, paradoxalement, le Coran est très
laconique sur le sujet.
La question du voile pour les femmes n’est
évoquée que très rapidement et de manière
assez vague à deux occasions.
Tout d’abord dans la sourate 24, verset
31 : “Et commande aux Croyantes [...] de
ne montrer de leur beauté que le strict apparent
; qu’elles ramènent leur khimar sur la
poitrine.”
Difficile de savoir précisément ce qu’on
entend par khimar au VIIe siècle, mais cela
peut sans doute être rapproché d’un fichu
ou d’un foulard.
On le voit c’est loin d’être inflexible,
ça rappelle plutôt une nécessité de pudeur
vis-à-vis des hommes adultes qui n’appartiennent
pas à la famille.
Le deuxième passage utilise un autre terme,
celui de jilbab, ce grand vêtement drapé
informe qui peut être ramené sur la tête
: “Prophète ! dis à tes femmes, à tes
filles, et aux femmes des Croyants, de ramener
sur elles un pan de leur jilbab : elles en
seront plus vite reconnues et éviteront d’être
offensées.”
(Sourate 33, verset 59) Ce passage-là a l’air
un peu plus strict, mais cela pourrait aussi
bien être compris comme un conseil et pas
forcément une obligation.
Le pan de tunique relevé sur la tête, peut-être
à la manière d’un sari indien, est censé
distinguer les femmes musulmanes des autres
femmes dans ces premiers temps de l’Islam,
afin qu’elles soient respectées en tant
que telles.
Voilà, ce sont les deux seules mentions de
voile pour les femmes dans le texte.
Tout le reste, le code vestimentaire punitif
et les tenues intégrales imposées, sont
des constructions postérieures.
En islam, la grande majorité des règles
de vie ne proviennent en fait pas des versets
du Coran mais des hadiths, les paroles orales
du prophète, rapportées a posteriori.
Les historiens spécialistes considèrent
aujourd’hui que ces paroles ont été forgées
et réunies bien plus tard, environ cent ans
après la mort du prophète, au début du
VIIIe siècle.
Ces paroles reflètent donc les traditions
en train de se mettre en place, après plusieurs
générations, plutôt qu’une vision prophétique
originelle.
En réalité, le port du voile devient un
objet d’attention pour les savants musulmans
des siècles suivants, qui interprètent le
texte sacré pour répondre aux enjeux de
leur époque.
C’est au fur et à mesure que le port d’un
voile couvrant la tête et le visage à l’extérieur
de la maison va devenir une obligation pour
les femmes.
L’explication donnée par plusieurs auteurs
musulmans du Moyen-âge pour justifier cette
innovation est le harcèlement que subissent
les femmes.
Al-Zamakhshari, un exégète du Coran qui
a vécu au début du XIIe siècle dit par
exemple : “Les jeunes gens et les hommes
qui courent les filles, harcèlent les femmes
lorsqu’elles vont dehors [...]. On a donc
ordonné à celles-là de se distinguer de
leurs servantes par leur tenue, [...] [de
s’] envelopper la tête et le visage, en
sorte qu’elles soient à l’abri de tout
harcèlement.”
(extrait de “Al-Kashshaaf”)
Là ça y est, c’est obligatoire.
Alors ça part peut-être d’une bonne intention,
à savoir protéger les femmes, mais la conséquence
c’est que la contrainte pèse sur elles,
et pas sur les hommes qui les harcèlent.
Exactement comme dans le texte chrétien de
Clément d’Alexandrie.
Ce sont les femmes qui doivent se cacher,
et les hommes qui les importunent ne sont
pas du tout inquiétés.
Des traditions divergentes
La comparaison du voile dans le christianisme
et l’islam pointe un paradoxe.
Celui d’évolutions complètement opposées.
Le Coran semble assez peu concerné par la
question du voile et ne délivre en fait pas
d’obligation stricte, pourtant le voile
est devenu au fil du temps une injonction
péremptoire dans la plupart des pays d’islam.
Au contraire, le christianisme part d’une
position très rigide, celle de l’apôtre
Paul et des pères fondateurs, qui veulent
absolument voiler les femmes, mais elle s’assouplit
petit à petit et tombe en désuétude.
En fait on le voit, un texte, ça s’interprète.
C’est ce que les institutions, religieuses
ou civiles, ont toujours fait.
Pour le christianisme, le voile féminin ne
correspondait pas vraiment aux coutumes européennes
et n’est devenu l’apanage que des religieuses,
celles qui se consacrent entièrement à la
religion.
C’est un uniforme religieux.
Par contre, c’est vrai qu’en dehors du
couvent, le voile n’est plus vraiment porté
par les femmes chrétiennes après le Moyen-âge.
Juste au moment de la communion et du mariage,
mais ce n’est plus un enjeu pour les chrétiens.
L’interprétation et l’usage ont finalement
contredit ce point de doctrine, pourtant c’est
bien écrit dans le bouquin.
Au XVIe siècle, le théologien protestant
Calvin l’a bien compris.
Il est moins attaché au voile en lui-même
qu’à rappeler l’infériorité des femmes.
Dans ses Commentaires sur l’Epitre aux Corinthiens,
il explique que selon lui, il faut “une
marque et un signe par lesquels la femme montre
qu’elle est sous l’autorité du mari.
[...] Or ce signe-là c’est la tête couverte
par un chaperon, un couvre-chef ou une coiffe
ou tout autre chose semblable.”
En fait peu importe ce qu’elles se mettent
sur la tête, tant que cela symbolise leur
soumission.
Cela témoigne d’un certain pragmatisme.
Calvin le sait, les mœurs ont changé, on
ne peut pas imposer aux femmes européennes
du XVIe siècle de porter un voile qui cache
leur visage comme dans l’Antiquité, il
faut donc en prendre acte mais préserver
l’essentiel : la domination masculine.
Le voilà l’enjeu.
Finalement, c’est pas le texte sacré.
Bible ou Coran, on l’a toujours tordu dans
tous les sens pour lui faire dire ce qu’on
voulait, et c’est normal.
On fait pareil avec les textes de loi.
Un même mot peut être compris dans deux
sens différents à cent piges d’écart.
L’enjeu, au bout du compte, c’est la domination
des femmes par les hommes.
Le texte sacré n’est qu’un prétexte
pour justifier un système patriarcal.
Après ça prend des formes plus ou moins
pénibles, Calvin est plus soft que les mollahs
iraniens, c’est certain.
Mais bon… le voile instrument de domination
masculine, c’est pas forcément une fatalité.
Une relecture des textes ?
Aujourd’hui, chez les croyants, et les croyantes
surtout, d’autres interprétations apparaissent.
Celles et ceux qui restent attachés aux textes
qu’ils considèrent comme sacrés, les relisent
parfois avec un œil neuf, plus en accord
avec les considérations actuelles d’égalité
des sexes.
Au XXe siècle, l'Épître aux Corinthiens,
ce passage du Nouveau Testament qui fonde
l’obligation du voile pour les chrétiennes
a par exemple été traduit de manière différente.
Les mots grecs de l’apôtre Paul sont tournés
dans un sens plus consensuel.
Annie Jaubert, une historienne spécialiste
des origines du christianisme propose par
exemple en 1972 de traduire le fameux extrait
comme cela : “En portant une coiffure, la
femme a sur sa tête le signe de sa capacité
à participer à l’assemblée des croyants.”
Subitement, le voile devient coiffure, et
la soumission devient pouvoir…
Une belle pirouette.
Ça permet aux chrétiennes du XXIe siècle
de toujours s’identifier au message de la
Bible.
C’est extrêmement intéressant de voir
que le texte écrit il y a deux mille ans
et qui ne répond plus du tout aux attentes
actuelles, peut être interprété très différemment.
Même chose dans l’islam, Aujourd’hui
certaines intellectueles comme la sociologue
marocaine Fatima Mernissi ou l’historienne
Latifa Lakhdar, qui a été ministre de la
Culture de Tunisie, veulent adopter une interprétation
plus égalitaire du Coran.
Selon elles, la vision originelle du prophète
Muhammad a été modifiée par l’influence
de ‘Umar, le deuxième calife et véritable
organisateur du texte sacré.
Ce serait lui qui aurait conduit à une vision
très inégalitaire dans le Coran.
Au contraire, le prophète Muhammad aurait
pu faire preuve d’une certaine modernité,
étant attentif aux critiques formulées par
ses épouses et ayant prononcé des paroles
plutôt favorables aux droits des femmes.
Il faudrait ainsi déceler l’influence néfaste
d’Umar pour l’atténuer et retrouver un
message plus authentique.
Les fameux hadiths, ces paroles rapportées
du prophète sont aussi convoquées dans ce
sens.
Le roi du Maroc Mohamed VI a par exemple rappelé
dans un discours qui date de 2003, qu’il
souhaitait : “Adopter une formulation moderne
en lieu et place des concepts qui portent
atteinte à la dignité et à l’humanisme
de la femme.
[...] A cet égard, Mon Aïeul le Prophète
Sidna Mohamed [...] a dit : « les femmes
sont égales aux hommes au regard de la loi.
»” Le roi du Maroc fait référence ici
à un hadith qui va dans un sens égalitaire,
et qui peut appuyer un changement de coutume,
sur le voile ou sur autre chose.
Donc selon l’état d’esprit et la volonté
politique, il sera possible de trouver des
éléments religieux pour étayer des décisions.
Finalement, on le voit, le voile n’est pas
une affaire de religion, ou bien à la marge,
c’est d’abord une question politique.
Et c’est pour ça que c’est un objet aussi
conflictuel.
Cela parle d’abord de la place des femmes
dans la société et de leurs droits.
Obliger / Interdire
On l’a vu, dans le christianisme, comme
dans l’islam, le port du voile est pensé
comme nécessaire pour protéger les femmes.
Pour les cacher, pour interdire la vue, pour
ne pas qu’elles soient importunées.
C’est tout le paradoxe aujourd’hui dans
les sociétés européennes, où le voile,
au contraire, rend visible.
D’autant plus lorsqu’il est intégral.
Cela transforme même celles qui le portent
en cibles d’insultes ou de discrimination
de la part de ceux qui veulent interdire un
tel vêtement.
Face à cette injonction de se dévoiler,
porter un voile devient une affirmation de
la liberté, un acte de résistance passive,
voire une manière de se comporter en martyre,
d’endosser les critiques pour prouver sa
foi.
Le voile peut ainsi devenir une forme de modernité
religieuse comme on l’avait évoqué dans
une vidéo précédente en nous appuyant sur
les travaux du sociologue Raphaël Liogier.
L’interdiction tant voulue par certains
est donc totalement contre-productive, en
plus d’être arbitraire.
Mais, si le voile peut être un marqueur identitaire
librement choisi en Occident, il reste aussi
un instrument de domination quand il est imposé
par les patriarcats les plus rétrogrades.
Le régime théocratique iranien en est l’une
des manifestations les plus flagrantes et
suscite des résistances de la population
depuis longtemps.
Depuis l’année dernière, ces résistances
ont même viré à l’insurrection, après
qu’une étudiante de 22 ans, Mahsa Amini,
arrêtée au motif d’un voile mal porté,
a été battue à mort par la police des mœurs
le 16 septembre 2022.
Le voile est devenu le symbole de l’oppression
du régime : de nombreuses femmes se sont
affichées tête nue ou se coupant les cheveux,
et des hommes se sont aussi mis à porter
le voile par solidarité avec elles.
Une manière de défier ouvertement le régime.
Pour finir, il faut dire qu’il n’y a pas
de morale à cette histoire.
C’est pas mon rôle que de distribuer des
bons ou des mauvais points, mais juste de
pointer les paradoxes et de préciser le contexte
historique.
Il faut juste rappeler que ce vêtement a
une histoire complexe et qu’il a toujours
été un symbole extrêmement puissant, pour
marquer un deuil ou le respect des dieux par
exemple.
Lorsqu’il est imposé aux femmes par certaines
sociétés au prétexte de la religion, il
est aussi le symbole de la domination masculine.
Mais c’est pas une fatalité.
Voilà, il y aurait encore une infinité de
choses à dire vous vous en doutez, on a finalement
parlé que d’une partie du monde, on a à
peine effleuré l’ensemble des significations
qu’on peut attribuer à ce vêtement, on
a pas parlé de la mode, de la symbolique
mortuaire pour les religieuses chrétiennes
ou même de tout l’imaginaire colonial orientalisant
qui a fantasmé le voile des femmes musulmanes
depuis le XIXe siècle…
Mais vous le savez, c’est une vidéo, on
fait des choix pour essayer d’aller à l’essentiel
et vous avez toute la biblio en barre d’infos
si vous voulez creuser.
MERCI beaucoup d'avoir regardé cet épisode,
avant de se quitter, j’ai une annonce à
faire : nous publions ce livre avec Lucas
Pacotte ! De quoi s’agit-il ? Si vous avez
aimé les formats courts, les fameux KOUDUR,
ce livre devrait vous plaire, il reprend certains
des thèmes comme Hannibal, Antoine et Cléopâtre,
en les développant.
Donc les anti-shorts, c'est pour vous ! Plus
sérieusement, si je devais résumer ce livre
je vous dirai que c'est LE livre qu’on aurait
aimé avoir en entrant à l’université
avec Lucas.
Donner en peu de mots les clés d’événements
emblématiques et de thèmes importants de
l’histoire antique.
En bref, se réapproprier la culture générale.
Vous pouvez le commander ici, et me suivre
sur Instagram et Twitter pour connaître les
événements prévus autour du livre ! Je
vous remercie de votre écoute, à dans 15
jours pour le dernier Mission Archéo !